[Music]  welcome to suburbicon a town of great  wonder and excitement with the promise  of prosperity for all you need to get up  [Music]  or something have the time those men  killed her mom we've decided it'd be  best if your auntie Margaret came and  stayed with us there will be strong  you'll be fine yes you know a character  named Rizzoli is a loan shark if you  were into the mob for money that might  explain what happened to your life this  is the best time that clown's gonna  ignore us take care of a kid  these animals took everything from us  like to make decisions like what's best  for the family any progress on the  investigation a mobster got killed a  couple of days ago sorry for his loss of  life yeah I guess he probably is too I'm  here to collect what do you want I went  all in it all of it nothing like this  ever happens here this is a safe place  it was  I could have you killed in no time  I could kill you two  [Music]